and so let's start there go around and
then yeah I would say that more than
women
why do you think that
who may yeah
um because I noticed that whenever
there's like these debates and stuff
they pick all the
things that they want that um benefits
them and then when the coins on the
other side then you've got to the
benefits of a man of what like rolls at
the man play the women all of a sudden
have an argument against it and it's
like
you're never consistent with your
arguments it's like it keeps changing
it's changing from each
where's he love him no because I was
thinking that's what it's funny meme
where it's like it showed like the most
blue haired like pink feminist right
she's like raging out in the streets but
the second she's in a burning building
she's like oh the innocent woman who
needs the man to help her because like
for life that's what she's precise I was
like yeah it's so funny
um I think a modern day woman is someone
who
doesn't necessarily who takes on roles
that is maybe for a man but
is but most of the time is due to
circumstances you know a lot of the time
it's due to circumstances I don't think
any woman actually wants to be a modern
day woman agreed yeah interesting yeah
circumstances yeah
it's hard to say but I think for me a
modern day woman is someone who wants to
do what they want when they want and
doesn't want to feel guilty for it I
think that's fair mm-hmm
I think a Monday woman is a woman who
has the freedom to choose
to
um
to indulge or go down roots that maybe
weren't available to her before
[Music]
um but I
I think I think a shift happens when her
priorities change but then sometimes
you know actions have consequences and I
think sometimes they're not always aware
of what those consequences are
I feel like you want to talk about
something specific this is General this
is just general General the warm-up
right now oh
um a modern day woman for me is a woman
that works hard
but
in her working heart it may give her a
sense of entitlement
and a modern day woman may not even
necessarily be a woman
[Laughter]
did you go yeah I agree with Paris I
think a modern day woman is somebody who
wants to have her cake and eat it I
think she's extremely lost and confused
in what she wants I think only when it
benefits her as she because
we want to work but then at the same
time we don't want to work we want
somebody to look after us yeah that's
why I said it's due to circumstances not
always not always circumstance I would
say experience more than circumstances I
think a lot of modern day women
um
base their beliefs on what's happening
in the past that has nothing to do with
them
oh other people's yeah yeah yeah but
that's life anyway everyone on Instagram
bases their beliefs on other people's
problems exactly I think as well we're
in like an era now which really
conflicting information about what a
woman's meant to like be yeah we've got
certain uh role models and like the
entertainment industry that are pushing
us whole like
um what's the word liberating lifestyle
yeah like you can do what you want and
they're not talking about the
consequences of it
um and then you've got like maybe like
your grandparents era where they're
teaching you all Traditional Values so
yeah it's a big it's very confusing I
think if you're stuck between that it's
like you're almost like what what do I
follow because what everyone in the
world but other sides of my family home
is telling me and if I look at like
traditionally what's happening it's
completely different so but those um
those women that sing all those songs
and everything they don't practice what
they preach oh yeah I know so true but
in terms of like the videos and stuff
and and what they're wearing and
everything hanging out like
they're doing that that's not the trick
for me personally I don't even though as
a celebrity quote unquote you have to
also be realistic that you take on that
responsibility or that knowledge that
you do influence people but I feel like
as an individual you shouldn't let those
people influence you you should have a
mind of your own yeah but I think that's
so gone I was gonna say I think that's
that's a bit of the double standard that
you want to be in the Limelight and with
that comes the responsibility to
influence but then you don't want to be
held responsible for True You're
influence true yeah so and also where
women are of of an age of Olden age so I
think that's easier for us to say but if
you're a younger girl like say 12 13
this year to this and growing up with
this this is this is all you know yeah
but the likes of some of those girls who
put those songs out they don't let their
kids listen to it yeah so as a parent
I'm a parent I wouldn't let my children
like for instance my children don't
watch TV during the week I control what
they do and how often they watch it
that's good and there definitely is an
element of control but still like
there's only so much control you can
have your parents and I know that when
my child my child goes to school yeah
have you ever have you ever thought
about like homeschooling because you
can't yeah oh my God yes because I I've
always thought that like the schools are
so bad and where I'm from Chicago they
took away grades
they took away yeah they took away
grades recently didn't just parcel fell
I don't know my mom just told me they
took away grades but Chicago's Chicago
is known for having like [ __ ] schools
like that's what we're and I'm like with
the the schools I'm like I almost don't
even want I don't agree yeah and the
thing is you don't know what they're
teaching your kids at school you know or
like how they're treating your younger
girl I was like at this Leisure Center
and I saw um they were like shuffling in
a bunch of like five and six-year-olds
and the way they spoke to these kids was
like so atrocious I was like oh my God
if their parents were here like if I was
their parent I'd be like don't speak to
my kid like that
you know I wish I had the time to
homeschool but as a modern day woman
yeah I have to work I'll be honest
though even if I was like a traditional
I know what my skill sets are and I
don't think teaching is one of it so I
wouldn't deceive to think I would be
good at teaching I definitely couldn't
do math yes
sir I thought when there's such a small
like young age everything is learning
you know like even a trip to the grocery
shop yeah I think they're teaching them
how to be like if there's a line to
teach them how to be patient yeah yeah
yeah
um even confidence building like okay
you pay for it there's so much earning
in everything just that's true we are
conditioned to think learning is in the
classroom just yeah there's so much more
good yeah there's like a thing called
World schooling
um I don't really know much about it but
I guess you just take your kid out into
the world and you're like is the world
learn yeah
we all had to start somewhere so there
was the world had to have been a
classroom at one point yes yes
what do you think Eddie what's a modern
day woman well she's not remember me
yeah
I think he's gonna hit the nail in the
head though I I think the modern day
woman is selfish
I think a motherly woman like you said
wants to have a cake and eat it motherly
woman it lacks accountability
woman hates men I don't know I said
Eddie you're getting quite comfortable
back there yeah I don't like the fact
that you're back there come do me son I
want to be looking at you exactly yes
say it with your chest Ellie yeah I just
think I'm not a woman is the things I
mentioned um quite problematic
um the main source of the problem to
modern day relationships oh my god um
I had a very similar answer on the show
you did
I I practiced it she rehearsed the lives
I believe I have it I have a delusional
narcissistic self-entitled feminist who
shits on men for her poor choices and
she was so happy when she was so proud
you know I was I was practicing in my
dressing room everyone came to get ready
I was already ready
sorry what were you gonna say
he's gonna get at me as many of you know
it's just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible